The Marines have a saying everybody wants to go to heaven but nobody wants to die
discipline means taking the hard road the uphill road to do what's right for
yourself and for other
People and sometimes a big part of success is just not being lazy and just doing it
Yeah, just get that's like 90% of its just showing up
What's that believe nation its heaven my one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan
Level talent at something and I want you to find it embrace it and use it to make a difference in the world
Now I started to believe life series to try to tackle different topics outside of just hardcore business instead of help
You live your best believe life today. We're gonna look at the one thing that only 1% of people do
enjoy
Dude
Screamed to me the other night a will I wanna be active man
I will be active just like you, you know, usually people say stuff to me like that
I'm like a man, you know you do is give them an encouraging word
But I was just sitting here thinking and it dawned on me
99% of
People that say stuff like that are not willing to do what it takes to make their dreams come true
the Marines have a saying everybody wants to go to heaven, but nobody wants to die and
That's just real at the center of bringing any dream into fruition is self
Discipline, you know something something as simple as food and eating it is not about your body as much as it is about
Your mind it's getting command of your mind to be able to choose actions that are in your own best interest
Every day we are choosing
That's not in our own best interest, right?
So if the world is attacking you and the world wants to fight you in the world's trying to hold you down
So you're gonna kick yourself in the balls
So you will stop yourself from getting what you dream
Self-discipline is the center of all material success
You cannot win the war against the world
If you can't win the war against your own mind, I always say that
Discipline is the loop of all good qualities
But you have to absolutely apply it
To things outside of just waking up early. It's it's everything
It's working now every day making yourself stronger and faster and more
flexible and healthier
Discipline is eating the right foods to fuel your system
It
It's about disciplining your emotions
So you can make good decisions. It's about having the discipline to control your ego
So your ego doesn't get out of hand and control you
It's about treating people the way you would want to be treated
and
Doing the tasks that you don't necessarily want to do, but that, you know will help you or help your team
It's about facing your fears
Takes discipline to face your fears so you can conquer them
And that's what discipline is discipline means taking the hard road the uphill road to do what's right for
yourself
and for other people
It's so often the easy path
The easy path that calls to us
to be weak for that moment to break down for that moment to
Give in to the desire and the short-term gratification
But the discipline will not allow that
the discipline calls for strength and fortitude and will
It won't accept weakness, it won't tolerate another breakdown
The discipline in seem like it's your worst enemy
But the reality is
Discipline is your best friend. It will take care of you. Like nothing else can and it'll put you on that path
The path to strength and health and intelligence and happiness
And most importantly
It'll put you on that path
To freedom it sounds like yo, you got to discipline yourself. I started looking at mother Teresa of
Gandhi and I was like yo, bro Gandhi would go fast from sex and he was married he would fast from talking
You know
I just started watching these great peoples like all these people fast and not about fast and like that's not the peace
but they were very disciplined people and they would not allow their exterior world to dominate or
Destroy their internal world. I just like you I want to get to a place where I can control me
My family members have grown a loss too, uncle cirrhosis of the liver. Brilliant, man
But just drinking drinking drinking and I was like yo, I do not want to my father was a substance abuser for years
I was like, yo, I don't want a life where something else is controlling me, you know
Like when I left home and said I don't want to be controlled no more
Like I meant that like, I don't know nothing to control me, but me and so I got to put myself under extreme
Discipline to make sure I'm free. So when people see me you get up at 3:00. You don't drink you don't smoke
I'm not doing that because I think I'm better than a BYOs
Oh
I think you gonna go to hell because you had a drink I just want I want to control I want freedom and for me
disciplining myself
means more freedom and unless I you discipline yourself people who I
Told my son other dads like your son. I do not want you to have fun
I just seen a history of people who just have fun Christmas Thanksgiving Halloween know
There are the people are still nice Friday
Every night there are the people who end up in a 20s having a great deal of fun
But in a 40s and 50s they were working for somebody
And I'm not saying nothing wrong with cleaning toilets
But they doing something they don't want to do for the rest of their life and they can't retire because they plays so much
You know, so for me, I just look at Venus in Sarina Michael Jackson when he used to like five and sixes dancing all night
I just think the more man discipline himself the greater
You don't mean it's gonna happen, but the greater the probability that he has this sense of freedom
well
I think the one thing that discipline definitely does help you with is it helps you get things done and
When you get things done when you actually do things you you you do you have more success if you have more success
Sometimes a big part of success is just not being lazy and just doing it
Yeah
Just get that's like 90% of it is just showing up get there and start working
Like you're not gonna feel perfect every day if I felt if I only worked out when I felt good, I'd be a theft
Because there's a lot of days I don't want to do it
if it's pretty much the same with everybody that if that actually
Gets good at something that you you get. There's got to be those days you push through
And they're them they're probably gonna be more numerous
Than the days you don't and so the benefit of discipline in my eyes has always been that through discipline I get things done
I always tell my always say that I'm like
The most lazy disciplined person. I know because I don't want to do it
Yeah
But I always do the thing about self-discipline is that it is necessary for everything you do in your life
You have to be self discipline if discipline comes from somewhere else
it's very very hard to remain consistent because you tend to resist it's wild because I see trainers and
they're in the gym with people and
you know the guy or girl that they're working out hates their workout hates it because
The discipline is coming from somewhere else you it's something that you dread every time you go in
You don't really want to do it. It's like oh, but oh no my trainers here
He's about to you know, beat me up and make me feel crazy. Well, the truth is every trainer
Should work his way out of your life
Anybody who's working you out your teachers your trainers your people they have to train you
To get out of your life now so you can go ahead do your work out do your own thing practice?
Self-discipline now one thing I want to straighten out big-time
Discipline is not punishment. It's not
Discipline it's training. That's all it is
I was talking to my son one time and I asked him it was weird because I was trying to see if he really knew
What it was all about and I said, hey man, you know, I have to discipline you what is discipline he goes
Punishment punishment when I do something wrong and you punish me I was like no
No
discipline is training if you change your mind your mindset and really
Focus it on what discipline really is you start to welcome discipline. You welcome self discipline into your life
Now I've got a really special bonus clip from Patrick Bay divided on how to develop discipline
But before that I want to know what has been the biggest struggle for you to be able to develop your own
Self-discipline leaving the comments below. I want to check it out
I want to help and hopefully believe me she can rally to help you too. So put it in the comments
Thank you guys so much for watching. I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in yourself and whatever. Your one word is much. Love. I'll see you soon
My guaranteed formula for success that is 100% proven for my life and other people have taught
Out work out improve outlast and out strategies again out work out
Improve outlets out strategize what you're looking on the screen here on the screen
Look at those four again what you're looking on on the screen here
Which of those four things that you're looking at the out work out improve outlets out strategize?
Which of those four things do you think comes last meaning? You'll learn the latter the latest it's out
Strategize why because that requires a lot of experience
It's like you got to go through like a general in the war, right?
You got to go through so many different words to learn different strategies and what works and what tactics works on what doesn't work
That's something you gotta be working on, right?
However, the other three outwork if a guy works 80 hours a week and you work 40 hours a week
You can't compete with that guy
If some if you yourself are
reading two three four books a month and you develop in your mind and your competitor is not
And he only reads one or two and you study in industry articles and all the subs and they're not you know
You're studying how to recruit CEO CFO CEO CMOS
What is the best way to stretch this million dollar investment that I got to make this happen?
Who should I talk to to be part of a group for mentors and CEOs group and all these who should I network with?
What community should I be a part of who's the best engineers IT firm to hire? What are these competitors doing?
what are some of the guys that are not even on my mark if you start studying those industry somebody else isn't it's tough to
Compete with you and then outlast some people work 80 hours a week for a year, and that's great
But they can't work 80 hours a week for three years some work 80 hours a week for three years
But you work 80 hours a week for five years
You outlasted the guy that the three years are one year
They can't compete with you because the compounding effort favors you so these four things that you look at on the screen
Require one thing and that's discipline and the discipline part. You don't hear a lot about that's the things people doing
Nobody else sees that's when you win if you tell yourself a story long enough you start to believe it
Don't you believe you act like I am Tulsa. What a whale out of handcuffed lightning both London's
Now, you know, I'm bad over the last week. I murdered a rock into the stone
Hospitalized a brick I'm so mean I make medicine sick
the fundamental
Key to success
is it can take between
Eighteen and two hundred and fifty four days of taking action for a new habit to stick
I've created a new course called 250 for confidence or every single day for
254 days
I will be sending you a video between thirty seconds and five minutes long that you start your morning with around making you feel
confident it's
Absolutely free. Check out the link in the description below to get access